hélène frade bonjour hélène bonjour tôt
line et on reparle des réactions au
discours on entendait un extrait à
l'instant discours hier en géorgie de
joe biden sur son projet de réforme
électorale projet pour protéger le droit
de vote des minorités menacées selon le
président américain dans plusieurs états
conservateurs à la bataille pour l'âme
de l'amérique n'est pas terminée a lancé
le président des états unis d'où le
discours jugé éloquent et passionné par
de washington post risque toutefois de
ne pas suffire à convaincre les
récalcitrants de son propre camp les
sénateurs démocrates qui refuse de se
ranger à ses côtés pour changer les
règles du sénat afin de faire adopter à
la majorité simple ces deux projets de
loi sur la réforme électorale
l'éloquence de joe biden qualifié de
grand dit que de grandiloquence absurde
par de wall street journal qu'ils jugent
inapproprié ses références à la lutte
pour les droits civiques le quotidien
critique un discours démagogique
associant selon lui à tort les loi
électorale votée dans un certain nombre
d'états conservateurs accusés de
chercher à rayer les minorités des
listes électorales notamment en exigeant
la présentation de pièces d'identité
pourvu de photos des documents dont
dispose essentiellement les américains
les plus favorisés le journal critique
donc l'association de sa réforme à la
lois jim crow la loi qui avait instauré
la ségrégation aux états unis incendie
politique au royaume-uni à présent boris
johnson fait face à une énième polémique
sur une là on parle d'une deuxième fête
organisée à downing street pendant le
confinement comme un air de déjà vu en
effet après les révélations sur une fête
organisée en décembre 2020 dont on a pas
mal parlé ici voici de nouvelles
révélations sur une autre fête organisée
elle en mai 2001 là encore en plein
confinement une petite sauterie
organisée en bonne et due forme à
downing street sous l'appelation amène
ta bouteille et chic est ce la fait de
trop pour boris johnson le daily mail
évoque en tout cas elle la crise la plus
grave qu'ait connue le premier ministre
depuis le début de son mandat déjà
passablement bousculé par les scandales
daily telegraph fait état du désaveu
croissant de braise johnson par les
conservateurs dont une partie le
pressent de présenter au moins ses
excuses si ce n'est celle des missions
dans le dessein de dave blom le nez de
beaux jo prend la forme d'un
tire-bouchon pour voir une bonne
bouteille de bordeaux ou plutôt de bozo
du château mend a cité comme mensah city
qui veut dire mensonge qui en veut une
bien fraîche propose le premier ministre
affublé d'un charte à motif qu vide dans
le dessein de bendjé ning sous la barre
sont le voir les pieds d'une victime du
coc vide des passes à la mort un mois de
la campagne pour la présidentielle en
france à présent à la une du quotidien
libération jean luc mélenchon le patron
de la france insoumise en inde dans un
long entretien le député des bouches du
rhône qui se présente pour la troisième
fois à la présidentielle persiste et
signe cette nouvelle candidature a pour
but de remplacer le système et non de le
réparer de rompre avec je le cite la
dictature du marché bref jean luc
mélenchon revendique encore et toujours
sa radicalité ne radicalité voir une
outrance qui l'a conduit notamment à
traiter des journaliste de france info
d'abrutis et de menteur des propos qui
ont valu à jean luc mélenchon une
condamnation hier pour injures publiques
et diffamation
on ne se quittent pas là-dessus à lui
s'est retrouvé condamné sur les réseaux
sociaux pour avoir pauline diffusé une
photo de sa femme déblayant la neige
devant leur maison de washington post
rapporte que john reyes un élu canadien
a été cloué au pilori par des
internautes totalement choqué qu'il
prenne son épouse en photos plutôt que
des lits lui donner un coup de main la
photo était pourtant légendée ainsi même
après douze heures de travail de nuit à
l'hôpital ma femme a encore l'énergie de
déblayer l'entrée du garage dieu la
bénisse elle et tous les travailleurs en
première ligne il est temps d'aller lui
préparer un petit déjeuner bonne journée
10 sympa merci beaucoup hélène et on se
retrouve un peu plus tard sur cette
antenne quelques mots de lacq